hemos pasado mucho tiempo hablando de
enantiómero estos son estéreo isómeros
que son imágenes especulares no
superponibles y tienen configuraciones
opuestas en todos sus centros finales
los días estéreo - también son estéreo
isómeros pero estos no son superponibles
y no son imágenes especulares por lo que
estos son estéreo isómeros que no son
enantiómero y los dias tere o menos
tienen configuraciones opuestas en
algunos centros quirales vemos este
compuesto
tenemos un anillo de ciclo propano con
un bromo y un claro por vídeos
anteriores sabemos que hay dos centros
finales este carbono es un centro quiral
y también lo es este el número total de
estéreo isómeros es 2 a la n donde n es
igual al número de centros finales y
dado que n es igual a 2 para esta
molécula esperaríamos tener 2 a la
segunda potencia o
stereo isómeros así que debería de haber
un total de 4 estéreo isómeros de hecho
2 a la n nos da un máximo de esteros o
menos posibles y vamos a hablar de eso
en vídeos posteriores vamos a dibujar
los 4 estero isómeros y echemos un
vistazo a la relación entre ellos
pensemos en cómo dibujar los 4 story
someros el primero podría tener ambos
halógenos saliendo hacia nosotros en el
espacio así que dibujar el bromo con una
cuña y el cloro con una cuña aquí
podríamos tener ambos halógenos yendo
lejos de nosotros en el espacio ponemos
el bromo con guiones y lo mismo con el
cloro y para el tercero story so meno
podríamos tener un halógeno saliendo así
nosotros pondré aquí al bromo y al otro
alejándose de nosotros
para el último podemos dibujarlos al
revés ponemos el bromo alejándose de
nosotros
y al cloro saliendo hacia nosotros
muy bien veamos las relaciones entre
nuestros estéreo y someros comenzaremos
con la relación entre el estéreo y
somero 1 y el estéreo y somero 2
para ello usaremos modelos moleculares
ya que son muy útiles en este área
química vamos a ver el vídeo del estero
y somero 1 y 2 en donde los átomos de
bromo están representados en color rojo
y los átomos de cloro están
representados en color amarillo en la
izquierda esté el estéreo y somero 1
ambos halógenos están saliendo hacia
nosotros en la derecha está el estéreo y
somero 2 con ambos halógenos lejos de
nosotros si sostengo ambos estéreo y son
menos juntos y giro el modelo de la
derecha podemos ver que son imágenes
especulares y no son superponibles si
alinea ambos claros
los bromas no quedan alineados y si
trata de alinear los bromas ahora los
claros no están en la posición correcta
por lo que son imágenes especulares no
superponibles estos son en anti o menos
vimos en el vídeo que 1 y 2 son en anti
o menos
son imágenes especulares no
superponibles y tienen configuraciones
opuestas en todos sus centros espirales
y eso es fácil de ver si nos fijamos en
los dibujos en este carbono tenemos un
promo con una cuña y si lo cambiamos por
iones vemos que tenemos este de la
derecha si nos fijamos en este centro
final tenemos el cloro en una cuña y
aquí que envía a tener guiones de modo
que tenemos configuraciones opuestas en
ambos centros espirales
y esa es una forma de saber que esta
molécula de la derecha es la imagen
especular de la molécula de la izquierda
es decir son enantiómero veamos ahora la
relación entre los estéreo isómeros 3 y
en la izquierda esté el estéreo y somero
3 con el bromo arriba y el cloro abajo
en la derecha este el número 4 con el
bromo abajo y el cloro arriba si lo
sostengo juntos y roto el de la derecha
es fácil ver que estos son imágenes
especulares y que no son superponibles
si pongo un claro encima del otro los
bromas no quedan alineados y si trata de
alinear los bromas entonces los claros
no quedan bien así que estos son
imágenes especulares no superponibles
estos son en anti a menos 3 y 4 son en
anti o meros son imágenes especulares no
superponibles y tienen configuraciones
opuestas en todos sus centros finales en
este centro final tenemos bromo en una
cuña y aquí tenemos al broma con guiones
en este centro de kidal tenemos al cloro
con guiones y aquí lo tenemos con una
cuña así que tenemos configuraciones
opuestas en ambos centros espirales
ahora vamos a comparar a los estéreo
isómeros 2 y 3 así que cuál es la
relación entre 2 y 3 en la izquierda
está el estéreo y somero 2 con el bromo
y el cloro lejos de nosotros en la
derecha está el 3 con el bromo arriba y
el cloro abajo si sostengo ambos estero
isómeros juntos y giro al de la derecha
podemos ver que estos no son imágenes
especulares los gramos están alineados
pero los claros no un claro está arriba
y el otro está abajo si intento
superponer los puedo conseguir que los
bromo coincidan pero los claros no y si
alinea los claros
entonces los bromas no quedan bien por
lo que estos son imágenes no especular
es no superponibles estos son vía stereo
meros en el vídeo vimos que 2 y 3 son
imágenes no especular es no
superponibles por lo que son días 0 -
voy a escribir eso aquí
2 y 3 representan un par de días de
omeros y los dias tere o menos tienen
configuraciones opuestas en algunos
centros finales si vemos este carbono
tenemos al bromo con guiones y aquí
tenemos al bromo con una cuña estas son
opuestas pero si nos fijamos en este
tenemos al cloro con guiones y aquí
tenemos al claro también con guiones de
modo que es lo mismo así que sólo
tenemos una configuración opuesta en un
centro final por lo que estos son días
tere o meros que hay de la comparación
entre el estéreo y somero 2 y 4 vamos a
ver el vídeo en la izquierda este el
estero y somero 2 con el bromo y el
cloro lejos de nosotros en la derecha
está el 4 con el bromo abajo y el cloro
arriba si sostengo ambos estéreo y son
menos juntos y giro al de la derecha
podemos ver que estos no son imágenes
especulares los claros están alineados
pero los bromas no
como está abajo y el otro está arriba
sin tanto superponer los puedo conseguir
que los claros coincidan pero los bromas
no se alinea los bromas entonces los
claros no quedan bien por lo que estos
son imágenes no especular es no
superponibles estos son 10 0 - 2 y 4 son
díaz stereo meros son imágenes no
especular es no superponibles y sólo
tienen configuraciones opuestas en
algunos centros espirales en este caso
sólo en uno si vemos este centro final
tenemos al broma con guiones y aquí
tenemos el bromo también con guiones son
iguales si nos fijamos en este tenemos
el claro con guiones y aquí tenemos al
cloro con una cuña de modo que tenemos
una configuración opuesta en un centro
final por lo que 2 y 4 son de estéreo
meros vamos a comparar los estéreo
isómeros 1 y 3 pensemos ahora en uno
para este no necesitamos un vídeo creo
que ya lo entendimos bien a esto si nos
fijamos en este carbono tenemos al bromo
con una cuña y en este carbono tenemos
al bromo con una cuña es la misma
configuración en este carbono tenemos al
cloro en una cuña y en este tenemos al
cloro con guiones son opuestos así que
sólo tenemos una configuración opuesta
en un centro final por lo que 1 y 3 son
día stereo menos uno del otro y es igual
para 1 y 4 estos también son día stereo
menos uno del otro